our main story tonight concerns healthc
care the thing that ER was originally
about before in later Seasons it really
became more about scenes like
[Music]
this wow obviously a lot going on there
not least of which if you're not
familiar with the e universe this guy
was already living with one arm because
he lost the other and this is true in a
different helicopter accident and you
know what they say hit me with a
helicopter once shame on you hit me with
a helicopter twice you must be in some
late stage post Clooney ER
Seasons specifically tonight's story is
about the healthc care currently offered
in jails and prisons that's right after
five long months we're welcoming you
back with a story about prisoner
Healthcare Because deep down this is Who
We Are
and I note that for some the very
concept of incarcerated people getting
Medical Care is somehow offensive as you
can tell from the fact that for years
the subject's been framed on TV like
this span County taxpayers are paying
the bill for alleged Killers rapists and
child molers to see doctors dentists and
Specialists have you ever seen a meth
user's teeth it's called Meth mouth and
it is awful a Kat anchor Todd Curts
shows you how all of that decay is
costing you money as jails and prisons
are forced to fix those teeth a place
where we are all guaranteed healthc Care
by law it's called jail and criminals
know their way around the system and
look for chances to get treatment on the
taxpayers dime okay it is just wild to
point out that the only place Americans
are guaranteed Health Care is jail and
somehow make it seem like the problem is
prisoners and not our deeply broken
system yeah apparently the only place
you can get free dental is jail are you
thinking what I'm thinking exactly
that guy and his teeth and putting aside
the fact that not everyone who's
incarcerated is even guilty it's worth
pointing out that according to a recent
study 100% of prisoners are actually
people I mean like human beings people
like the kind that you are they have
hopes and souls and farts and brains and
if that isn't enough you should know the
Constitution requires that we provide
adequate Health Care to anyone behind
bars in 1976 the Supreme Court ruled
that denying medical treatment to
prisoners constitutes cruel and unusual
punishment in violation of the e8th
amendment yet despite all of that the
quality of care prisoners receive is
abysmal investigations in state after
State have found it to be woefully
deficient and a lawsuit against Arizona
a while back made some horrifying
allegations it alleges that prisoners
are at quote substantial risk of pain
amputation disfigurement and death it
cites examples of prisoners being told
to prey to be cured or drink energy
shakes to treat cancer symptoms okay
that is both terrible advice and also
not even close to being true if energy
drinks could treat cancer symptoms you'd
have heard about it Red Bull would
mentioned it in all of their ads instead
of their current marketing copy which is
Red Bull there's nothing we can do about
the taste but let's be honest you're 22
and hung over and just need something to
get you through your shift at Red
Lobster and you're still a few years
away from having cocaine money so just
shut up and put this poison in you and
the thing is the consequences of poor
care are only going to get more dire
given our rapidly aging prison
population from 1999 to 2015 the number
of people 55 or older in prison
increased by
264 per. and why are we confining so
many elderly people in prisons when we
should clearly be putting them where
they belong on the golden Bachelor
taking full advantage of menopause and
raw I presume that's what happening on
that
show so given all of this tonight let
let's take a look at prison Healthcare
who provides it why it's so bad and how
we can improve it going forward and
let's start with the fact that at one
point States themselves provided medical
care for their jails and prisons some
still do in fact and in most places it's
generally been pretty bad that treat
cancer with prayer and energy drink
story is from when Arizona ran Its Own
Prison health care but increasingly
states have started Contracting care out
to private companies as of 2018 more
than half of all US states hire private
companies to provide at least some of
their prison health care and when it
comes to our largest jails that number
is more than 60% all of which explains
why this is now a roughly $4 billion
industry and the sell companies make is
that they can tailor care to the
particular needs of the incarcerated
population that can have high rates of
Substance Abuse and Mental Illness both
of which do pose special challenges just
listen to this promo for advanced
Correctional Healthcare which serves
facilities in 21 states as it makes a
very big promise
the purpose of advanced Correctional
Healthcare is to solve problems for our
patients and clients and make their
lives easier in fact our data indicates
your detainees will be healthier in your
jail than they are when they go to their
own doctors well that definitely doesn't
immediately seem like does it
from the fact that she's citing our data
to the fact that when you're Googling
for best doctors near me the top result
is very rarely have you tried your local
jail and unsurprisingly the rosy picture
that promo paint doesn't remotely live
up to reality take this story from a
Wisconsin jail that used that company's
Services 6 months ago 39-year-old Dante
Wilson was in a Wisconsin jail for a
child support violation he complained of
chest pains the jail nurse concluded he
had heartburn and gave him two Tums less
than an hour later Wilson asked for help
again relax was the nurse's advice soon
after Wilson died of a heart
attack the nurse told the the detective
Weeks
Later the nurse was fired good she
should have been because that is the
single worst thing you can possibly say
in response to someone dying of a heart
attack because you screwed up and what
I'm sure that she was upset at losing
her job if I may share a quote that it
seems there is simply no bad time for
happens and at this point
you will not be surprised to learn that
in internal trainings Advanced
Correctional Healthcare seemed to spend
an unnerving amount of time teaching its
employees what constitutes the legal
bare minimum of care that rough draft
Jennifer Garner wax figure once
conducted a video seminar for staff
titled a jail is not a health Spar and
just watch her explain the importance of
avoiding deliberate indifference
basically not blatantly neglecting to
treat prisoners by using the weirdest
possible example so how do we Define
deliberate indifference now you must
know of and disregard an excessive risk
to inmate health or safety something
which would cause the unnecessary and
wanting or malicious infliction of
pain a few years back there was an NBA
player who was arrested for shooting a
gun into the air five times outside of a
strip club that is criminal recklessness
that is consciously disregarding a
substantial risk of harm a stray bullet
could have hit a stripper okay that is
definitely an exalt
although to be honest it only really
makes sense if she explains every legal
concept like that abduction a stripper
gets kidnapped bankruptsy a stripper
stops stripping escrow a stripper buys a
house but enlists a third party to
temporarily hold assets until the deal
is finalized now you should know that
woman was the company's senior counsel
and I'm happy to announce that she is no
longer in that role but that's only
because she's now the president of the
whole company
yall
woo but the problem isn't just with this
one company it's with the whole industry
a review of 500 jails found those
relying on the five leading contractors
had higher death rates than facilities
run by the government and one of the key
reasons companies so often deliver
substandard care is that they are
actively incentivized to due to how they
are paid it's basically a fixed dollar
amount contract it's $16 in change per
prisoner and the cont contract assumes
34,000 prisoners so it's it's basically
this is how much we're giving you and
the more money you spend on providing
Health Care the less profit you make
right and that's a pretty obvious
incentive to cut Corners if if you give
your babysitter $100 and say whatever
you don't spend on dinner you can keep
don't be surprised if you come home to a
very happy babysitter and a bunch of
pissed off kids eating Top Ramen and
that profit motive has led to some
pretty outrageous policies a recent
court case against Wexford one of the
country's largest prisoner healthc care
providers revealed that for years it had
had a deao one good eye policy as when a
69-year-old prisoner got cataracts in
both eyes and wanted them fixed the
prison doctor told her that she'd have
to make a choice which eye did she want
fixed the right one or the left one
which is clearly an impossible question
it's like someone asking which property
brother you'd like to kill the only
acceptable response to either question
is both why are you making me
choose but to show just how dangerous
these companies can be let's just look
at one state Arizona back in 2009 it
announced a plan to switch from State
care to private providers and the
initial pitch was that this would be a
cost-saving measure but as this woman
explained something interesting happened
fairly early on they put out a request
for proposals in RFP and nobody bid for
it because nobody could do it for less
than what the state was spending cuz the
the state wasn't spending very much as
it is a couple years later the
legislature came back and said oh we're
going to amend that prior law remember
where we said it has to be less it's
okay it can cost more oh it can now can
it oh so so you demanded a competitive
Bid And when no one responded you just
rolled over and gave up absolutely
everything it's a shrew tactic from the
famous book on negotiating this is where
I'm softi and other business ideas by a
timid puppy but since then it has been a
nightmare as Arizona has cycled through
contractors they started with Wexford
the one good eye people but as things
didn't improve less than a year later
they switched to a company called
corizon but almost immediately heinous
story started emerging about the care
that they were providing too including
one that we've actually shown you before
on this show about a woman who gave
birth Behind Bars and whose c-section
wound hadn't fully healed and I'll let
her mother pick up the story from there
they decided she had been there long
enough that she could go back to her
yard but it was still open a little bit
and so they decided decided that um the
best thing to do for this would be to
pack it with kitchen sugar sugar sugar
and we're talking sugar that you get
from cuz they donate it from McDonald's
from Burger King you know they're
standing there ripping open these little
packs of sugar and filling that wound
packing it in with what's left and with
sugar from a fast food restaurant yes
okay let me be clear I'm not a doctor
although if you put me in a lab coat I
do think I could get away with it for 2
to 6 weeks I have an accent I don't know
how to say subdural hematoma I'm
basically halfway there already but if I
had to pick the worst possible thing for
a person recovering from the trauma of
childbirth it would probably be
injecting McDonald's sugar straight into
your bloodstream and the state lawmaker
who spearheaded the move to take
Arizona's prison healthc care Private
John kavanau didn't display a great deal
of empathy when confronted with that
story that sounds ridiculous you know
prisoners have uh you know 24/7 to think
up allegations and write letters I'm not
saying that uh that some of them can't
have a basis in fact but you got to take
them with a grain of salt or in the case
of the hospital BBE a grain of sugar oh
I get it a joke prison jepetto here is
having some fun with words and I'm sure
that prisoner sides were splitting less
from laughter though and more from the
open wound that thanks to him she had
filled with sugar and that is
just one of many stories of carizon
providing abysmal care seemingly in
order to cut costs not only were they
repeatedly accused of refusing to play
Specialists causing hospitals to have to
send emails like this one in which they
literally beg for payment but when a
corizon doctor was dealing with a
prisoner who'd had multiple seizures and
suggested sending him out for an exam
she was told that that was not going to
happen but that they'd order a helmet
for him to protect his head instead and
while it is clearly not the most
important thing here we tracked that
doctor down to ask if they ever got that
helmet for him and you'll never guess
what the answer was unless your guess is
no in which case you're absolutely
right and all of this led to
horrific consequences like this man who
had just 10 months left on his sentence
for vehicle theft when he complained of
back pain four months later he finally
got x-rays done which showed signs of
cancer but even then corizon dragged its
feet they wouldn't do an MRI they kept
denying an MRI denying an MRI in May CT
scans were ordered to see if vogi had
cancer but corizon denied it finally at
the end of July 2013 a CT scan was
performed it confirmed vogi had cancer
medical records showed there was a
lengthy delay in treating vogi and it
was kidney cancer that could have been
95% survivable and now they're saying it
I can't survive it whatsoever vogi was
granted medical parole so he can die
surrounded by family that is a tragedy
just 10 months left on his sentence
showing clear signs of cancer and
nothing was done and again he was in
there for vehicle theft the punishment
for that is clearly not death but under
a system this cruel it can turn out to
be and this was all part of a consistent
pattern the state's own records show
that corizon had delayed delivery of
Medical Care 16,000 times in just one
8mon period it got so bad Arizona was
actually forced to pay fines for the
substandard care prisoners received even
as mystifyingly it continued to pay more
than $2.5 million in performance bonuses
to Horizon's exec Ives but eventually
enough was enough and the state got rid
of corizon the company fun fact has
since declared bankruptcy but rebranded
as yes care which is a bold name choice
for that company it's like Applebee's
calling itself won't make you poop weird
to put it mildly your name is a little
misleading anyway Arizona replaced
carizon with a company called Centurion
but the situation still didn't improve
in fact last June a judge ruled that for
years across multiple providers the
state had shown the most callous and
inhumane indifference saying no
legitimate Humane system would operate
in this manner now since that ruling the
states contracted out to yet another new
provider this one called navare which
itself is finding accusations of
forcibly inducing pregnant prisoners
into labor against their will and that
is the thing here in so many places
states end up just rotating among a
small handful of awful providers prisons
in Florida have gone from using Wexford
to corizon to Centurion Alabama went
from corizon to Wexford to yesare which
you remember a basically just corizon
rebranded so States choose Health Care
Providers like old married couples
choose sexual positions by cycling
through an extremely limited number of
options none of which really get the job
done in a satisfying way and the options
can be so limited that even when public
officials do try to do the right thing
and demand action they can often find
themselves stuck take what happened in
foresight County North Carolina it had a
a contract with a company called correct
Care Solutions to provide care in its
jail but after a series of calamities
including two men dying in the space of
just 24 days this County Commissioner
decided to vote against renewing their
contract and did so like this I can't
vote to support correct care for any
contract you know I don't care about 3
million three years or whatever I
wouldn't give correct Care Solutions
$3,000 for 3 days if I hear my way so I
can't it right that's a pretty strong
know from that man as and as completely
justifiable as his reluctance to renew
correct Care's contract was as the
County's deputy sheriff pointed out to
him there was a bit of a problem the
only thing I will say Sir is uh with
regard to this this was correct care was
the only uh vendor that beid it's true
there was no other option so the whole
vote was basically ceremonial it' be
just as effective to hold a vote on the
question should it be summer now yes yes
everyone votes yes well bad news
everyone it still isn't and when you put
all of this together it's hard to escape
two conclusions that all the options
currently on the table are bad and that
the reason they are allowed to be so bad
is because of who this care is for and I
get that it can be difficult for some to
care about issues affecting prisoners
and I also get that their health care
may be especially difficult to Rally
around as so many on the outside don't
have health care themselves I know all
of this but the fact remains prisoners
are people
100% of them are in fact and there are
some solutions here I would argue that
the bare minimum we should do is to stop
Outsourcing prison Healthcare to private
companies as the Director of the
national prison project of the ACLU puts
it government run prison Healthcare is
often appallingly deficient but at least
when a government is providing the
service there is some measure of
oversight and it should say something
about just how bad things are that what
activists are pushing for here is the
appallingly deficient option and look
obviously ly the problem is so much
bigger than just shitty contractors if
the issue is that prisons are
overwhelmed with too many patients to
take care of maybe there should be fewer
people in there if it's that prison
population is getting older because of
the incredibly long sentences that we've
imposed on people maybe we should
consider releasing them if it's that too
many of them are dealing with addiction
and mental health problems maybe we
should be examining whether prison is
the best place to treat those conditions
because the thing is it is impossible to
separate this issue from the much larger
convers ations about universal
healthcare and prison abolition like so
many stories that we cover this one ends
at the Perpetual elephants in the room
that the US doesn't guarantee any of its
citizens the Dignity of good health care
and it puts too many of its people in
cages cages where many will needlessly
die and you can take that with all the
grains of sugar in the world but it
should still be absolutely impossible
for you to
swallow